[Music]
[Applause]
ah
charles barkley would never get into
altercations like that on the floor hall
of famer inside the nba
tnt analyst what would you have done if
patrick beverly did that to you when you
were playing
well uh and first of all dan do you know
what time it is
it's 9 24 east coast time
and i'm i'm only up at 9 24 because of
your ass dan
there's no reason i got nothing to do
today but relaxing
and i'm only up because of you that's
how much love i got for you
um you know it it depends on the
situation like chris paul's got to play
in the finals so he can't get into any
fish to cuffs
but it was just a punk move by pat bev
you know he did what he when he tried to
uh almost hurt crystal now he danced
over him when he was on the ground
uh and now he can't take it when the
when the rabbits got the gun
so it was just a punk move pat bell is a
good kid
he works hard but it was just a punk
move plain and simple
do you think it was a successful season
for the clippers
yes uh considering they had never gotten
to the
conference finals to get there without
uh
kawhi it was a great season i mean think
about it dan
they had never gotten to the conference
finals before
and to lose your best player and get
there
and beat the team that was the number
one seed i think you can't consider it a
success
why is there speculation that kawhi
could leave the clippers
well i think uh number one
before we decide that we got to figure
out how bad his knee injury
is that's the first thing and then i
think he's gonna have
he's gonna sit down with his team and
say
are we good enough to win the
championship in the next couple years
i mean i think that's a big decision to
be honest with you
because it's kind of hard to say right
now because you know the lakers are
going to do something
are they better than the jazz i'm not
sure they beat the jabs i'm not sure
they're better than the jazz
are they better than the sons so i think
kawhi
he's holding all the good cards right
now he's going to get to pick where he
wants to go
if you're kawhi do you want to stay in
with the clippers have you seen enough
when you say even though that's where
you wanted to go back to
yeah you know that's a good question dan
i really don't know the answer to that
um because you have to be in the locker
room because
you have to say to yourself is platoon
going to stay
is sergey bakker going to stay what are
they going to do with reggie jackson
uh because he's going to get paid so at
the end of the day
it might just mean you you and paul
george you have to ask yourself
i can go anywhere i want to you know
i've heard the rumors about him going to
miami
or new york which would be a great
destination so
that's a good question i don't know the
answer to it yeah dallas has also
been mentioned uh we're talking about
dallas playing with that boy porzingis
that would be a really good thing also
well i think they'd have to give up
porzingis
like you you would pair him with luca
yeah i know i mean oh you met luca yeah
yeah um like him and luca would be nice
together
yeah yeah for sure all right the buck's
playing without giannis
we see teams that do this and usually
it's a one-off where you step your game
up when the star player is out
um how surprised were you with the bucks
last night without him
wasn't surprised at all danny dan number
one i want to say i want to thank you
for all the kind words doing the
documentary
um thank you for the kind words uh
but i wasn't surprised you know dance
what's interesting about these games
i always tell people there's until you
go on the road and do your thing
that's when you figure out the thing
like atlanta who played great at home in
game four
that wasn't the shocker to me uh the the
bucks playing greeted home last night
that wasn't a shocker now can they go on
the road and do it to me that's when you
find out
who's like legitimate and who's for real
so
uh man i have no idea what's gonna
happen uh
to tomorrow night all those guys from
atlanta they're gonna play better at
home
but the bucks the bucks played great
last night but can they take it on the
road to me that's the key
and charles was talking about a
documentary they did on inside
the uh nba on tnt and uh a variety of us
in the media we talked about
how difficult it is that you guys make
it look easy and
uh you know it all starts you know with
ernie
to be able to land planes at uh at jfk
but
you know they got to have you batten
batten cleanup without you
it's it doesn't work uh on the magnitude
that it has
well thank you for the kind word you
know listen man we're so lucky i i
ernie is we call him the godfather
because he's the man
and shaq and kenny are awesome to work
with but you know there's so many you
know dan
uh you you've been a star for a long
time
and you show up and you just have to be
dan patrick but there's so many
people around you who do so much heavy
lifting
so you know i mean unless you're in the
business you have
zero idea how it actually works i mean
there's so many people around you
who number one feeds you all the facts
and uh you just show up and you're older
older decent looking man uh and you just
have to be damn patrick
but also you you guys have allowed your
producers to make fun of you
and you're all stars and that damn damn
damn
we're talking about stupid basketball i
always
you know it's so funny with me when you
know i i've been a thing for 36
years i tell the guys when they start
taking themselves too serious like
yo man you do know you play basketball
right
you're not like a doctor or somebody
who's in the army
oh it's a teacher a fireman a policeman
people got like a real job
you dribble a stupid basketball you make
more money than god
to just dribble a stupid basketball when
you start taking yourself too serious
you need to take a step back like yeah
i'm really not that important i just
play basketball that was a nice
documentary everybody loved it
there's the last dance documentary that
it still seems like that's
bothering scottie pippen uh what did you
make of scotty's comments when he was on
with me earlier in the week
you know i'm disappointed in scotty
because he's burning every bridge
i know he has a book coming out listen
scotty was a very good player
i've always liked scotty too i've always
liked him i i've never had a
disagreement or an
argument with him but he's taking shots
at me
um and i'm just laughing because i'm
like yo man you do know we're like 60
years old
we don't have beasts anymore we're like
60. what we accomplished was 30 years
ago
it's not important or significant uh it
was great
in the day but now it's irrelevant so i
was disappointed he's taking shots at
michael phil jackson and myself
but i understand he's got a book coming
out and
i just think it's silly and stupid to be
honest with you listen hey we know you
got a book coming out
stop trying to make uh you know take
shots at
big fish he's big game hunting you come
out to myself you come out to mike you
come out the field jackson
hey we know you got a book coming out
but it it it really just makes you look
stupid and silly in the long run to be
honest with you yeah
stuff that you stuff you haven't said in
30 years
then i've been retired for 20 years can
you imagine that
and so that that stuff happened like 25
30 years ago
and to come out now seeing all these
things because you have a book coming
out
and i guess he has the alcohol coming
out and you know we're
and unfortunately we're in the business
so every jackass
gonna have you on if if you're gonna say
something bad about michael jordan or
charles barkley or phil jackson
you're gonna be on every tv show and
that's the thing i just feel sadness for
him more than anything
i didn't think there was strategy behind
him what he said about phil jackson i
i think he's been carrying those 1.8
seconds when he sat down in that game
against that playoff game against the
knicks
and the the last dance documentary just
sort of
gave a whole new generation of hey this
is what happened
to mike and this is what happened to
scotty and i and i think he
probably you know it's like yeah i'm
gonna
i'm gonna start i'm gonna give you my
ver my episode of the last dance
well you know for me dan i have to take
the good and the bad when people talk
about charles barkley
i don't get to sugarcoat like everything
i did stupid
in my life the spitting incident
the dui people get to bring that up
i don't get to talk about how great i
was at basketball
without saying some of the when people
say
okay yeah but he did some stupid things
and
that's just the way it works like i got
a dui
i spit uh back in my day
like i have to take the good with the
bad and
you know when michael listen michael
when he did the documentary
uh he had to say some things that scott
did wrong
and scott was still was a very good
basketball player but he did some things
you know not having surgery not going
back in the game
when you talk about your life my life
your life
todd's life every little nerd you got
working for you
you don't get to say hey this is all the
good
i did when you did when you do things
that are not good
you have to talk about those also
there's some things i'm not proud of
i've done in my life
but you you have to talk about those
things
and it sucks when people bring them up
i'm not going to lie it sucks when
people bring them up
but hey i've done more good than bad
we had uh chris weber on yesterday we
were talking about jamal mashburn
telling a story about the dream team
when the
college guys were scrimmaging against
you guys
and rodney rogers upset bird by
kind of calling him out and and mash was
telling the story and then c
webb was backing it up saying bird just
you know magic fed bird like eight or
nine times straight
and just ate his lunch what do you
remember about that moment
you know lad bird is one of my favorite
people in the world
i always tell people you know playing
against bird mchale in paris the
greatest front line ever
i always laugh about larry because
larry's like
chuck i need to talk to you in the
middle of a game there uh dan he's like
i said what's going on larry he's lb
he's just
y'all being disrespectful to me i'm like
what do you mean he says
y'all got a white guy trying to guard me
that's disrespectful
i'm like it caught me off guard i'm like
what do you mean he's like
no there's not a white guy on the planet
can guard me y'all got a white guy i
think
i think it was i think it was bob
thornton at the time bob burton one of
my favorite teammates he's like
hey man listen y'all being disrespectful
don't ever put a white guy on me
and i i've only heard michael jordan and
lara bird are the only two guys
larry michael says to me in the finals
like chuck
you're being disrespectful i mean like
and those are the only two guys that do
not put a white guy on me a white guy
case taught me
when michael and larry said that i still
laugh about that today when i'm out with
the guys telling cause they always want
to know stories i said library was a bad
boy
but he's like he's like hey do not put a
white guy on me that michael said the
same thing
a white guy can't guard me and quit
doing it i was wondering about this name
image and likeness now with college
athletes and
like if you were at auburn right now
you'd be cashing in yeah dad but i'm
concerned
uh okay there's a couple reasons why i'm
concerned
number one the ncaa they're just
boneheads they're like
they're done knots they're the barney
fights of life
they don't have no idea what's going on
but let me be serious here for a second
number one
i hate when people tell young black kids
getting a free education is nothing
uh getting a free education is a really
really big deal
i hate when people tell black kids well
they're not giving you nothing
hey going to college for free and then
you know a lot of people who are still
paying college debt to this day
getting a free education is a really big
deal
so that's my first issue my second issue
and like i say i don't know anything
about this but they
they they act like everybody in college
now is gonna start
rolling in the dough and i'm saying well
that's not true nobody's gonna be buying
the
offensive lineman's jersey he's not
gonna get a car deal
now the quarterback and the running back
and maybe a star defensive player
they gonna make some money but like i
say people are gonna buy their jersey
and they might get a car deal they might
even get a restaurant deal
but most of the players which they're
not gonna make
any money but this notion that wow
this is gonna be great for college
athletics all these people gonna make a
lot of money
i don't believe that they're the backup
guy
or or somebody like that yeah charles
barkley would have made a lot of money
in college
uh probably chuck person but that's
pretty much it
on our team oh uh bo jackson at my
college at auburn the greatest thing
i've seen is bo jackson
is play college football he's gonna make
a lot of money
but what really bothers me and scares me
about the whole scenario dan is
there's gonna be so much resentment from
my other teammates
but they're like damn charles is selling
jerseys
he's got a car deal we work just as hard
as
him same thing with bo jackson like the
offensive lineman
he opens up all the holes for bo jackson
if bo jackson is making all this money
and the offensive lineman who actually
do all the work they're not making a
dime
i think there's going to be great
resentment and jealousy on these teams
yeah i think that's a great point by the
way you're part of the uh
capital ones the match there uh with
uh tom brady and bryson duchamp aaron
rodgers
and uh phil mickelson you're you're an
analyst on the course
yeah uh i have no idea what tnt is gonna
have me doing i'm gonna be doing
something
but let me just tell you something i
just i'm just disgusted by phil
mickelson i cannot believe
that he want to play with this mother
instead of me
he like that's exactly right dan you
heard me wow
me and phil were the defending champs
but they i can't believe he gonna stick
with this mother
i can't say what tom said but i can't
believe he want to stick with this
mother instead of me
we are the defending champ but he what
has tom brady did in the last
year to make him more important and so
difficult than me
how would you do straight up against
brady in a match
oh hey overrated overrated
he's overrated flash in the pan i don't
know if he's ever going to be successful
at anything
you know i think tom is the greatest
first of all he's a really nice person
he's a really nice person i think he's
the greatest athlete
arguably ever i do i truly believe that
i mean he's clearly the greatest
football player ever but i think he's in
a conversation with ali
michael jordan wayne gretzky
uh those are the greatest ever in my
that's just my personal opinion but he
might be the greatest ever
and he's a really nice guy but i like to
bash him because because he got a great
sense of humor
uh but uh tom i don't think tom can beat
me in golf
i really don't not right now he can are
you going to corner aaron rodgers and
ask him what the hell is going on here
with the packers so we can finally get
an answer out of him
you know i'm going to give him something
i'm going to give him something about
that
because number one if i had a dollar for
every time i heard about avon rogers and
the
and the packers this summer i have more
money than you then
i'm sick of it i'm sick of the the
four-letter network
talks about it every single day yes they
do and there's a reason we call
the four level network dad that's just
between me and you you know
i'm really sick i'm really sick of the
aaron rodgers
you know the nfl and you know football
and boxing are my two favorite sports
but the nfl man they hog the spotlight
every single day man nobody like i'm so
sick of talking about football
every day it's not even football season
and we still talk about it every single
day
it drives me crazy uh good luck to your
phoenix sons there
i'm really excited uh it's great for the
city i'm really happy for chris paul
i'm really happy for him because you
know you know i'm one of the few people
who
actually know what he's going through
when you've been a great player your
whole career and your team is not good
enough to get
get to the finals you know it's a tough
burden to bear
and uh he got to the finals and now i
hope he can win it
because you know hey dad i'm on the list
um
i'm on that list where you know people
say he never won anything so
i always root for guys to get off the
[ __ ] list and i'm pulling for chris paul
good to talk to you as always you look
great and uh have fun there at the
at the match here in montana you know i
can't wait i've never been to montana
i can't wait to get there uh i'm looking
they say it's beautiful
i can't wait to get there uh so it's
gonna be fun hey dad uh
i always appreciate you man i'm going
back to bed
uh i'm i only got up to do your show but
i'm going back to bed so you take care
of yourself
have you ever shared a room with shaq
before no
no i shared a plane with him and i
thought there was a grizzly bear on the
plane with me
this thing snores dude snore hey dan i
did
we've we've flown i think we've flown
three times together and he fall asleep
i think there's i said yeah we got a
grizzly bear on the damn plane this is a
lot
he's the loudest known person in the
history of civilization dad it's
unbelievable
well plus he's one of the largest men in
the history of civilization too
he is one of the largest people but i'm
tell you something when he starts
snoring
man i'm telling you like i'm like it's
crazy how loud it is
you gotta tape it next time you should
play it on the air
on tnt next time he nods off just record
it
it's not a nod off it's like a full
blown grizzly bear
on the plane with you thank you chuck
all right guys thanks for having me you
guys have a great fourth of july weekend
thank you mike that's charles barkley
nba on tnt